if you're ready for german dancing food
celebration and beer you're ready to hit
oktoberfest at hoffer house las vegas
mercedes there is they're live right now
to kick off this evening's festivities
hey mercedes
hey jc pros we are having a great time
here at hofra house las vegas
oktoberfest is in full swing i'm joined
by patrick barrett the general manager
we talked about the beer can we talk
about some of the amazing food
traditional german food here at hofstra
house las vegas and of course you can't
you got to start with the pretzel um my
favorite thing about these pretzels
though are the dips that come with it
can you tell us a little bit about it
well we've got two different kinds of
mustard and then what you see here is
what's called albata which is a bavarian
cheese specialty it's a mix of cream
cheese green cheese some butter and some
paprika oh my gosh
that's so good no double dipping here
i'll keep it here and of course the
pretzels are imported from germany
they're traditional so soft so delicious
okay let's move on to some of the more
traditional dishes and i know this one
is very popular it's one of our very
popular oktoberfest specials on friday
nights it's the roulade and it's a
braised beef roll and you have beef and
then we put mustard
bacon
sauteed onions and it's rolled around a
pickle spear and then it gets seared and
then it's slow cooked in a uh
the the sauce that you see there which
is a brown red wine sauce look how
tender it is it's just coming off of oh
my gosh this looks amazing and then of
course it comes with your traditional
mashed potatoes mashed potatoes that's
correct
okay the red cabbage red cabbage i some
people think cabbage ew but this
this is not your traditional cabbage
tell us a little bit about this
it's our our special recipe our red
cabbage that goes out
with a lot of our meals it's a little
bit of a palette cleanser in between
courses here and these specials among
just so many different german delicacies
are available here at opera house las
vegas not just for oktoberfest but year
round let's talk about the party that is
happening tonight and tomorrow fridays
and saturdays october 5th you have the
celebrity keg tapping i get to do it on
october 30th and you've been teaching me
how to do it tonight though who's
hosting tonight we have frankie moreno
singer frankie mourinho will be here
tonight tomorrow night we have magicians
marie sawchuck will be here and it is
going to be filled in here of course we
have all social distancing measures in
place and we are going to have a great
time so come on down here and join the
party not just this weekend but every
weekend through the end of october i've
been practicing are we ready
this is my sixth one so i mean hopefully
i'll be okay here
we love it mercedes have fun and we're
gonna check back in during the 4pm
newscast so opera house las vegas as
they mentioned so tonight we got frankie
mourinho and then on october 8th mark
schnuck the 22nd gordy brown and the
mercedes will be out there on saturday
october 30th